today's topic we're doing a follow-up
from the guy who brought you
uh i managed to find a girl there
and by that time i met her
we were just friends it was chill she
was actually a terrible human being
this man is killing me
when i first met the first girl in my
life
that wanted to be with me and i spent
seven years with that girl and i regret
it
very much
and i felt like i was gonna search
youtube
for people with the same issue as me and
that is being
really unattractive we bring you an
update video yeah just for a little bit
more context uh originally this video
he was really hard on himself and really
felt like he wasn't going to be able to
find anybody et cetera et cetera
um he's too ugly and sure enough he
seems to have
found somebody hey there and welcome to
another video
hi and i this is just a simple update
video
for obvious reasons i haven't made a
video in like
what is it five weeks i think five weeks
or so
because lullaby is here he's finally
here
i've been distracting him i've been
distracting him
[Music]
my name is
hey hey you already know
they doing the grown-up they're doing
their taxes hey
they filing as a married couple you know
some
booths knock some boots knock some boots
you got to knock your boots before
you go in yeah i'm back for you bro yeah
channel is kind of declining a bit
and the discord server is kind of dying
because of it but
this is kind of important for for me in
my life
so good value your real life
relationships someone's in front of you
don't forsake their your time with them
to spend time with people online
there's a person in front of you giving
you physical proximity
don't be up on the discord wasting your
time that's right anyway we're
gonna talk about how we met
right when was it february 3rd yes
so we started writing to each other
february 3rd she found
me through my youtube channel
she wrote to me on discord and
after a few weeks or days i don't
remember
we started liking each other
and how long time did it take before we
met february we met in
like march june um
i think we met in when i came here yeah
that was like uh
beginning of april yeah april
oh wait so it wasn't even march it was
march
damn brother how much you've been
[ __ ] that you don't remember live
your life
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] live your life i mean
they were distracted
we mean you've been uh distracted i'm
very bad at these things
i mean i am too but yeah we've been just
having lots of fun
uh getting to know each other better
bonding
you don't see if you're laughing he's
like we've been having lots of fun
getting together and i heard bondage and
i was like
he really just said bonding but i heard
bonus because you're left
uh we've been to the cinema we've been
taking walks
right bikes yeah and we share common
interests
so we play games together watch movies
[Music]
we're playing through knights of tall
republic on the tv together
yesterday we shot hoops
for those who don't know anything about
sports or anything that's like
basketball you shoot at the with a
basketball
at the cage so yeah uh lately there
hasn't been much video so
i've been pushing out the stream here
and there when i've had the energy to do
so
god damn girl you're draining him
what are you draining him he literally
said this he's not draining him he's the
one who's pushing up the stream
oh oh when he's had the energy
in the cage shooting you know hoops
balls deep
good for this guy i'm just happy for him
yeah yeah i'm super happy now look
part of that is also like he broadcasted
himself to the world
via youtube so that doesn't hurt your
chances
you know considering he's also not that
outgoing necessarily exactly you know it
makes it harder
but it does go to show that you know
considering they're still together and
they're working and they're enjoying
each other's company
there's somebody out there for you or a
few other people out there for you just
gotta find ways to make that work
sometimes that's across international
borders who knows it's not easy
i don't know but it's okay what do you
mean no there's not gonna be someone
necessarily for you if we take
the different parameters right distance
that you
likeable to meet that person or just
uh timing and someone something some of
y'all are gonna die alone
just because someone's gonna die alone
doesn't mean there's not someone out
there for them
those two things are very different cool
i don't think there's someone for
everybody
yeah there's somebody most people can be
loved by somebody in this world
it just doesn't mean that you're going
to be together yes exactly do you feel
what i'm saying yeah yeah
i'm trying to say okay cool we agree
yeah okay we agree yeah i'm not saying
everyone's gonna end up with somebody
okay yeah that's not what i was saying
oh okay i just said there's someone out
there
for everyone the same way there's a car
out there for you
don't mean you're gonna get it no right
don't mean you can afford a lamborghini
exactly but at the end
it's just good to see stories kind of
turn out well and to see somebody
be able to improve on their situation
and i think that's something that most
people should be able to take away from
this there is something
out there for folks i thought that was
pretty cool what are your thoughts on
the whole matter at the end
i'm happy for him that's pretty much it
yeah super dope that everything worked
out i'm happy for you
yeah and if it doesn't work out at the
end take that
as an opportunity to know that it can
still happen
yeah so you know it's not
infinite or definite or whatever it's
not you know it's not casting stone
things can happen but know that you
actually can
yeah obama and think about it too he was
brave by putting himself
out there and saying a lot of this stuff
and um
recognize that if you're in a similar
situation where you feel like there's no
opportunity like
you have to make some effort to put
yourself out there these things may not
necessarily come find you
put yourself out there and you'll be
surprised by the results at times
not is it going to work but at least you
tried it increased
your chances yeah exactly so that's what
happens
if you don't try then yeah you're
definitely going to fail so
that's pretty much my thoughts on the
matter if you don't drive you're
definitely going to fail
what do you guys think about this topic
we want to hear from you
so just just don't give up all right and
uh
i know we laughed a little bit we kind
of cracked some jokes but just also
be sure like we're not mocking you and
we're not trying to belittle you we
understand it's a real problem
but i would just say you don't have to
give up
so that's pretty much all i got
[Music]